i would not count facebook out it's
still the number one social network it
still has like grand total in the whole
meta family of apps is well over three
billion active users now to your point
just a minute ago where
um the last earnings call in q4 2020 for
the first time in facebook's 18-year
history they started to lose users about
half a million and what didn't really
make the headlines is that half million
was daily active users they still went
up 20 million monthly active users
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres the host of this
show and i'm so grateful that you are
here we are helping you build your
youtube influence and turn that youtube
influence into a high impact and high
profit online business and i want to
welcome all of our new listeners thank
you for being a part of what we're doing
here at think media and if you've not
already subscribed wherever you're
getting this content hit the subscribe
button so that you get all of the
episodes that we produce here on the
podcast and if you've not already gone
over to our think media podcast youtube
channel we're dropping bonus videos
bonus shows over on that channel so make
sure to subscribe over there as well
well i'm excited for today's podcast um
because we're jumping into facebook now
you might be thinking okay but
facebook's kind of dead heather like are
people really there yes people are still
on facebook we've got the facebook queen
herself mari smith on the episode today
to dive into why facebook is alive and
thriving and what are some of the new
features that you need to know about
when it comes to being a content creator
on this platform we have all that and
more coming up in today's episode but i
want to let you know that if you've not
yet signed up for our think master class
you can do this by going to
thinkmasterclass.com this is a one hour
class where we dive into the three
secrets of success to youtube and sean
cannell or myself do a free live class
for you where you can learn how to
dominate on youtube this year all right
well let's jump into today's featured
content all about facebook with mari
smith
[Music]
welcome back to the think media podcast
i'm so fired up because it's like an
annual tradition even though there was a
couple weird years there with pandemics
and whatnot
but to have mari smith the queen of
facebook
in a conversation to figure out the
state of the union what's happening on
facebook you know what are the
opportunities today we're going to be
talking about
ads we're gonna be talking about reels
video
groups and so a lot of topics that i'm
personally fascinated by and i think
that we love facebook even though we
talk about youtube so much um and so
mari first of all how are you doing how
has your last couple years been
i'm doing great i'm so grateful to be
able to pivot to on stage in physical
live reel in person
and to do all virtual and it was
interesting in 2020
you know my revenue went way up my
expenses we don't so less travel and
there you go a lot of demand wow it's
amazing and here we are back in person
and uh you know facebook has gone
through some crazy stuff i'm curious
first of all the state of the union of
course there was the major headline
where facebook lost 25 of its value and
its stock shares in one day the greatest
drop in history truly meta it's called
meta now i mean you know and there's so
many things happening give us kind of
just an update for those who maybe are
counting facebook out confused about
facebook what's happening
sure so first of all i would not count
facebook out it's still the number one
social network it still has like grand
total in the whole meta family of apps
is well over three billion active users
now to your point just a minute ago
where um the last earnings call in q4
2020 for the first time in facebook's
18-year history they started to lose
users about half a million and what
didn't really make the headlines is that
half million was daily active users they
still went up 20 million monthly active
users so yeah they've reached saturation
the growth isn't as meteoric as it was
in previous years it's still the biggest
social platform in the universe and we
still as marketers and business people
got to be using it yes zuckerberg is all
in on video we've seen this massive push
for reals you know he's competing
heavily with tick tock i think it was
late
2020 that adam asari head of instagram
said that tick tock is quote unquote the
most formidable competitor we've ever
seen wow and as you know meta you know
previously facebook but the meta family
of apps they are renowned for copying
like crazy right stories was a direct
copy of snapchat reels direct copy of
tick tock and that's what they're
historically do they see what's working
for other social apps and go pedal to
the metal and so as marketers absolutely
we need to be doing video as much as
possible it doesn't have to be all the
short form though you know when you go
to upload a video natively to creator
studio one of the little check box
checklist says is it um over three
minutes so they actually want us to be
doing three to five minutes even longer
why
because they can monetize with ads ad
breaks right plus as you probably know
tick tock recently increased from three
minutes to ten minutes before long
zuckerberg meta being so great at
copying i'll bet you that sooner or
later we'll see 10-minute reels wow well
at least they'll grow
over the coming you know months and
years
because these platforms are really
becoming destination entertainment
creators big focus on creators with a
personal profile now on facebook you can
not everybody but some folks will be
having an um option to switch over to
what's called professional mode
so you don't even need a page anymore
wow now caution this is not for every
business person if you're a creator true
creator and you're generally using your
personal profile you don't have a page
or you're really not using your page
much
then you get the option for professional
mode i would recommend making the switch
yeah you're going to have monetization
tools analytics metrics probably get a
lot more reach for your reels for
example example and so on so
man i love it and so let's break down a
few of these pieces you know i'm i'm
pretty active on my personal facebook
page and i know that it's a business
angle but i know that more family and
friends are there we're very active on
my fan page we have multiple groups but
reels is kind of a new one to me i don't
think we've posted a reel yet we've
posted reels
reels on instagram
and vertical video on tick tock which
kind of the same format so so what is
even just the breakdown the the upload
of a real is it in the feed and is it
just vertical and under a certain amount
of time yeah so on instagram it's 30
seconds and on facebook excuse me uh 60
second reels on instagram and for some
reason they've only made it 30 seconds
on facebook and you can go in to create
a reel directly on the publisher on your
page on your profile and in groups
and i actually personally i'm not too
excited about how they are
um published the real is because when
you go to make one and it goes right
away on the wall
and so like i said i do three wheels in
a row let's say and it goes bam bam it's
right on my wall and it just doesn't
look right on desktop it does look fine
on mobile and of course we know eighty
percent use facebook on their mobile but
uh what we're seeing for sure in the
news feed is reels has its own dedicated
tab and then also when you start
scrolling down there's this horizontal
swipe of these you know algorithmically
chosen reels and you know the more you
watch of one type the more
of that type you'll see you watch little
dog videos you keep seeing dog videos or
whatever the case may be so is it as
simple as uploading a vertical
less than 30 second video 30 or less
yeah and then and then or recording but
according to camera just discerns it as
a real yeah is there native uh
music integrations oh not just uploading
it not to the feed you do have to use
the reels tool or the wheels camera got
it very much like the stories camera
okay right so there's a real camera so
typically you're going to be uploading
from mobile
correct correct correct got it for now
for now we'll see they'll see because
they added the ability to upload stories
on creator studio and in business suite
uh to do stories and to schedule stories
so eventually when the demand's there i
think we're gonna be able to do
uploading and even scheduling reels and
that's probably one of the biggest
features i i get asked for certainly on
you know instagram and facebook amazing
okay and so then
coach me a little bit on the difference
between how i should be approaching
reels versus stories and my activity on
stories which is nice is i'm active on
my instagram stories yeah connected to
facebook so those end up on my personal
profile on facebook which i've which i
love because it actually has kind of
just opened up not even another piece of
work that it just naturally gets shared
there but i can go that'll end up in
messenger on facebook and since open
other conversations that's just i'm
doing literally no extra work and it's
doubling the efforts truly but speak to
stories personal page fan page and maybe
your personal approach and thinking
about the difference between all the
things to do and incorporating stories
into your business absolutely well like
yourself i typically will originate a
story on the instagram stories camera
just seems to have a little bit more
native tools so i'll create a story
there or upload and then i have that
automatically synced up to my business
page because i have a personal uh which
i could change then yeah i have a
profession it's called professional use
called business professional account on
instagram connect to the page but then
really cool what i do is on my
facebook personal profile if i have
something just a little more personal
and i will originate it from my personal
profile and then that pushes to
instagram so i've got all three bases
covered and my goal is to have a story
at the top of feed you know in there
every one to three stories in every 24
hour period but not necessarily seven
days a week i might you know skip a few
days let it kind of reset bump back up
to the feed
and it's just generally a little more
informal casual intimate behind the
scenes whatever it might be and still
thinking strategically like a marketer
and whereas reels
rails just seem to be
so short like micro little tidbits of
content
highly entertaining and thinking about
okay what i'm about to create is not
going to disappear and it will be
potentially in the feed for a long time
potentially could go really really viral
and we do have to put a little bit more
thought and effort into the creation of
our reels but they can be outtakes and
repurpose little snippets of all kinds
of other video they have already and
that's a great distinction reels can
live forever stories are going to expire
in 24 hours and so as we go deeper down
the rabbit hole we can be and should be
utilizing reels we can do stories which
are ephemeral they will disappear and
then we could also be posting square
video
vertical video feed video and we should
be embracing that as well absolutely
yeah three minutes or more you're saying
as well on facebook for sure for sure
yeah and the thing is that now instagram
has really been kind of shifting its
identity remember when adam asari says
we're no longer a photo sharing company
they're really going all in on video as
well because it's all about having these
mobile devices in our pockets that are
for entertaining and and they're really
leaning into the creator economy which
is great uh but not every business is
you know in the creator category so but
yeah we need to be thinking about these
four different types of video we haven't
talked about live because you got to do
live streaming as well live on instagram
on facebook then you got your feed
videos and you get your stories and you
get your reels so yeah a lot we're
breaking it down okay so live now on
instagram it's typically vertical
integration of bringing a guest on is
great right yeah on facebook it could be
vertical and also you could also bring a
guest on and do that vertically from
your phone
we typically
are multi-streaming we a lot of times
we'll stream our coffee with candle show
or youtube made simple show with heather
taurus
to our youtube page with streamyard and
also to
a fan page if not also a group yeah i'm
curious if pushing a multi-stream or or
using different apps could hinder your
reach if your thoughts on that and then
just your a general approach to life
that's what we're doing what what do you
think we should be doing in the think
media podcast community when it comes to
live streaming you know if your your
audience are already kind of diversified
and they're going to find you in a
variety of different places well
platforms you meet them where they're at
i'm a big fan of doing the
multi-streaming i personally don't do it
i tried a little bit last year and i
just for me because i'm like all about
facebook i use the third party app ecam
and i just go live on my page and i'm
focused on the audience there even
though i know like stream yard they
aggregate the comments and there's
others that do that too
but um
i you go vertical i mean horizontal i
yeah i use my desktop horizontal do you
have uh with ecamm
banners pop-up or anything or is it
mainly just kind of
it's talking here but i always share my
screen and now i love to share my phone
people are always like how are you
sharing your phone on the screen how do
you do that oh just hook it in you just
wire it into your ios and on a mac and
because he comes only for mac and then
it's just a camera source so you can
teach off your phone you share your
screen kind of like a webinar or share
your screen to show people how to do
things yeah and it's picture-in-picture
because you're there in cameron always
use a good dslr camera like you're the
king of videos so it's just it looks
professional quality this is some great
so these are great tips ecamm live use a
mac you can share your phone teach from
your screen share your screen and then
really create some really high impact
content i mean i'm envisioning the whole
thing right now that's very yeah that's
incredible yeah you don't have to use a
mac there's ways to absolutely mirror
using a pc and you can use android
phones so it's probably e-cam's pretty
easy for you as well how often do you go
live well it just depends like i can go
live once a week and i'll go through a
period where i'm just like really
focused on teaching a course and i just
won't go live as much i'm focused on
teaching my course yeah and and then
i'll you know so average about once a
week but sometimes i'll skip a few weeks
so okay so as we uh land the plane we've
we've talked through this front side of
a video but now we still have the
opportunity to do short form combi long
form copy um mike selzner here at the
event we're at social media marketing
world was talking about the power of
just those
engaging like ask a question and is it
called just a facebook image where it
turns your text into i call them colored
backgrounds
colored background one of the most
effective it can seem at just kind of
getting attention making a question a
little bit larger in the feed give us
some of your thoughts about and now
tapping into photos written word and the
best posts working on instagram right
now on instagram i'm sorry facebook yeah
yeah yeah uh number one is facebook live
yeah
followed by photos there's five so
live first then photos then videos of of
at least three to five minutes if you do
photos is it just just a photo photo
with some copy is a copy short or long
photo with copy and a call to action
i'll link i'm always a fan of putting
call to action and a link now you will
see a lot of studies out there will go
short short short captions i'm like i
write little mini blog posts yeah i've
done that for like over a decade and it
just the algorithms know that my
audience knows that so i think test test
what works for you and for your audience
so photopost um yeah absolutely with
with some information in there then the
video three to five
then a link post and then a status which
is called a status which could be just
text
or one of these colored background which
i love and asking a question i
personally don't like to do it too often
you kind of bug my audience with all
kinds of questions but but they do
definitely perform quite well i know
social media examiner doesn't like 90 of
their posts or those questions
eventually it's not gonna work but you
know
run with it while you can sure that's
great and then one other thing that we
had discussed touching on was now we're
doing all this organic posting there's
still massive opportunity on facebook
number one social platform and still
growing yes
um pay to play
ads
what is your philosophy and what should
we be thinking about in terms of paid
advertising on facebook so here's the
thing i have what i call my amplify
method so what you do is you start with
video ideally live it doesn't have to be
video but it's really good if you do
video and what you're looking for is
what my friend larry kim calls your
unicorn post and a unicorn post is
performing reach engagement maybe about
10x better than the other posts okay so
test it organic first get it
unicorn status
and then do the next step yeah and they
have a really cool feature they met at
facebook inside of creator studio where
you can do it's called post testing so
you can do a b testing organic for free
up to four different versions of a video
post like same video maybe chest
thumbnail test the title the caption
they're just getting us ready for for
ads right so it's like oh that works
okay so now what you do you got your
unicorn video and you're going to go
ahead and go into ads manager you can
use the boost button if you want but i
like going into ads manager you're going
to just amplify the reach get that video
views as high as you can from there
you're going to go in and build custom
audiences video views custom audiences
of varying sizes right the minimum is
three seconds all the way up to like
half or 90 percent split testing all
that retargeting those video viewers and
then expanding with look-alike audience
and what that's helping marketers to do
in the classes i teach my clients is to
somewhat mitigate the
damage or the issues around the apple
ios add tracking transparency because
the pic the pixel the cookies crumbling
we've got to find better ways to really
kind of milk and make and you know
maximize the data that's already
available to us with people who are
engaging with our content and video
views is really powerful way to do that
and i always say every time you post
something
you you're creating what i call boost
worthy content you're like is this
worthy of even a dollar yeah i don't
just create content as okay check a box
we did our social today it's like
thinking it through strategically with
those
end games in mind and the calls to
actions and the links and if you put if
you find a unicorn and you put some paid
traffic around that is your ultimate
goal eventually to just maybe in some
cases reach more followers to build a
brand but in other cases then retarget
with a follow-up ad that's a call to
action to whatever it is you want to
happen in your business absolutely both
it's both yeah absolutely yes and what
is your cadence you spend a little bit
money in awareness and brand building
versus also business building if you
will or direct response marketing in
terms of a call to action yeah i would
do for me personally i wouldn't do as
much on the awareness side but someone
who's really starting out has maybe kind
of a young page and not a lot of
followers and but really dialing down
your customer avatar and your targeting
parameters and then building that
awareness and followers but ultimately
isn't necessarily about getting
followers it's really about getting that
traffic leads and sales and just you
know differentiating between we've got
our social metrics proxy metrics i call
them and then you've got your business
metrics your traffic leads and sales and
don't ever you know lose sight of the
prize at the end of the day
brilliant mario smith queen of facebook
now what are you up to lately of course
uh give a call to action to your your uh
following you but um you're the person
to follow to learn this stuff so i mean
you've got some what can we be a part of
what how can we connect with you so
certainly my social scoop facebook group
we're closing in on 20 000 members a
wonderful supportive community for folks
who've got anything around social media
especially on facebook and then in my
talk in a couple hours i'm going to be
opening the doors in a brand new
community called mari smith's superstars
wow there's marios superstars.com and
it's built on mighty
networks mighty networks is a community
platform where you can have your own
basically your own social network
founded by gina bianchini who's the
former founder of co-creator of ning wow
you remember ning back in the day but
mighty network is so powerful so you can
have your own basically like your own
quiet peaceful oasis away from facebook
to have a community and you can do
courses and memberships and whatnot so
many nuggets marty smith so much respect
and just gratitude for you taking the
time to pour into our community and
thanks again for uh being on my pleasure
thanks for having me
all right so are you ready to jump back
in on facebook i know i am after
listening to mari and all the cool new
features available it's so cool to see
that that platform is still thriving and
i think that if you have the opportunity
and you have enough time that you should
be investing in facebook as well
well thank you so much for being a part
of what we're doing here at think media
and it's so encouraging to us to be able
to get to read all of your reviews and
thank you for rating and reviewing the
podcast today i'm going to read this one
from wh main wh maine says the podcast
to listen to if you want to crush it on
youtube man that's such a think media
phrase thank you for saying that this
podcast is practical no-nonsense guide
to being successful on youtube it is
packed with interviews and information
from people who are actually doing it
every week there is something new to
think about and apply to your business
think media's podcasts are easy to
listen to engrossing funny and
entertaining all at the same time
you don't want to miss one video if you
care about your youtube channel and no
no no one paid me to say this it's the
absolute truth actually w h main i'll
make sure to paypal that over to you now
i'm just kidding thank you so much for
being a part of what we're doing here at
think media thank you for leaving that
review and saying all of those kind
things the five stars too thank you so
much i want to say that we are here to
help you grow on youtube as well as
other platforms like facebook but you
got to make sure that youtube is your
staple that's where you start when it
comes to spending your time on growing
your online business invest in youtube
first and then figure out the other
social media platforms like facebook or
instagram or tick tock that you should
be a part of as well well i want to
thank you for joining us on today's
episode we have so many great podcasts
in the works for you so make sure you
subscribe wherever you listen to
podcasts on and we'll catch it in next
week's episode
bye
[Music]